οελιθθώ σταυγό και δίνουμε συνέχειατόφηματ εξαρεταί δε δίνουμε λεφτά εμείς εκτόσαν είνα πληρώσεις κάποιο λογαριασμό
έτσι με απόδειξη αυτά αλλά είναι συτόφημα γουρχισμό αχρειάζεται κάποιος ξεχθα γεννήσει πάματα για τον
ο η κρεβατάκια και δεί σείδος βοηθούμε και έχουμε πάγα από πάγα πολύδου πάγα πολύ
δουλεια εμείς ανεριθώς θαυγός έχουμε και τους μετανάστες που έχουνται στον εριθ σταυγο που είναι
μια δύσκολη σελίδα γιατ για την κύπο δι ότι είναι αρκετί πλέον και αλλά δυστυχώς
πρέπει μπορείσαμε βλέπεις μια οικογένεια που υποφέε ο φίλης νατι βοηθήσεις χτύπησε αποτε το τηλέφωνό
σας και στην άλλη γράμμη να είναι να τομο τοοποίο είχε τόση πολύ ανάγκη που
σας κατέφυγε σε σας αφού δεν έβρισκει άλλη λύσει έτυχε αλλά βεβαίως τα ηλέγχουμε γι
ότι ξέρετε σε αυτές τις περιπτώς εξέχεις πάντα πρέπει να τα ηλέγουμε και υπάρχει ελέγχωσις
το ιδικά τον εριθθό σταυο ελέχουμετρες περιπτώσεις και να μου τηλεφωνίσουν και να μουζητήσουν κάτι
θα το ελέξουμε και μετά θα βοηθήσουμε όπως καιτο άλλο που πιστεύω που με εγώ
τισατε πρι γιατί ο έρηθθος θαευγος ας πούμε έχει τηυποστηρίξη που έχει από τον κόσμο
γι ότι ξέουν ότι και στεκάνουμε τον έγανο καπνομε διαφορές θα διδηλώσεις μαζεύουμε λεφτά αλλά
ξέχουμεται θα θα δώσουμε μπίσω στον κόσμο και ότι θαπροσέξουμε πολύ ότι τα ελευτά που
παίγνουμε να πιαίνουν εκεί που πρέπει σε τά αθωνα το φυλανθρωπικό έργο προσπαθίσατε μέσα σε
αυτά